Martin Starr Tommy Ford dead at 52  et can confirm the actor most famously  known for his role in the 90s sitcom  died Wednesday in Atlanta Georgia  Tommy's co-stars reportedly came  together to support him at the hospital  as his health declined the actors rep  said in a statement to ET quote it is  with great sadness that we announced the  untimely passing of our beloved son  father brother husband and friend Tommy  Michael forward on behalf of the family  we would like to thank everyone for  their love support and prayers  Martin Lawrence was the first from the  Martin caste to speak out on social  media sharing this candid shot of the to  writing prayers for my brother Tommy for  that the Lord watches over him and his  family through this difficult time  tisha Campbell a ka jina also shared her  condolences simply writing I love you  you